where to even start today uh the last 24
hours have been um uh almost surreal
here in the united states let's start
with what exactly would i do about guns
you know one of the things that has come
up in the last 24 to 48 hours uh after
we've had not only the buffalo shooting
but also now the uvalde texas school
shooting has been when people say we've
got to do something about the guns there
will be those on the right who say what
exactly do you want to do steve kerr the
coach of the nba's golden state warriors
went on this impassioned rant and many
like ben shapiro and others said i don't
hear any specific suggestions there so
let me give you my specific things that
i would try
with a couple of caveats as we get into
this whatever anyone proposes whatever i
propose whatever is ever proposed
you will always have people saying
that won't solve the whole problem this
one idea won't solve the whole problem
of mass shootings or even the sub
problem of mass shooting specifically in
schools and they're correct
this is such a widespread issue
that no one
thing will solve or prevent every mass
shooting but that's a reason to do many
things rather than to do none so that's
number one you know no one treatment
cures all cancer
blood pressure medication alone doesn't
prevent
all strokes and heart attacks but you
say well let's do blood pressure
medication
exercise diet meditation whatever seat
belts don't stop every car death but we
say seat belts are one tool safe for
cars or another crash testing is another
road design is another driver education
okay
i also saw a post bemoaning that the
left has all the same ideas as to what
to do as we had 10 years ago we've tried
none of them of course we're going to
have many of the same ideas we've not
tried any of these things and many of us
believe that they would work so uh let's
get into
the list of things that i would do
and go through them one by one first
we've got to end the gun show loophole
the gun show loophole refers to the fact
that federal law doesn't require
unlicensed private sellers like me if i
just have some guns and i want to go to
a gun show and sell them there's no
federal law that requires a background
check for gun purchases uh that's the
gun show loophole okay you've gotta you
gotta close that number two universal
background checks when we talk about a
universal background check it would
require
essentially every firearms transaction
in the united states to be recorded and
to go through the national instant
criminal background check system and
that is sometimes called the private
sale exemption you've got to deal with
that universal background checks aren't
required by u.s federal law you've got
22 states and dc that require them for
at least some private sales but that's
got to go federal number three we need a
mandatory waiting period from the time
that you go and you say uh i want the
gun
to the time when you get the gun
absolutely imperative you've got to have
a mandatory waiting period four
what about no high capacity weapons for
those under age 25 you can get your your
your you know single action uh uh
firearms or your handgun i guess at age
18
but you've got to wait until age 25 for
certain high-capacity weapons number
five mandatory gun insurance maybe even
gun insurance that's more expensive
without a parent co-signing if you're
under 25 i'll get back to that
what about a required community support
letter for anyone under 25 who wants a
gun meaning you've got to have
i don't know sort of like you would have
two or three references for a job
you need two or three references from
people over age 25 if you are under age
25 i'll get back to why that may be a
really important thing
number seven we probably want to ban
some weapons yes they're there we
already do it right you can't get nukes
you can't get shoulder-mounted rpgs
uh we might just expand that list a
little bit there are simply some weapons
that are of no real value except as mass
killing machines i'm not pretending that
i have the exact point at which you draw
the line but we probably want to look at
that number eight a periodic mental
health evaluation including when you
first obtain the firearms
all these right-wingers saying the
problem is mental health well okay let's
do something about it
require an initial and a periodic mental
health evaluation number nine an
extensive licensing process okay you
need a written and practical test for a
driver's license it should be the same
for guns also the training and licensing
period shouldn't be one weekend it
should be longer like with cars uh and
we do we should have a gun buyback
program okay that will make the off-ramp
for lots of people much more reasonable
there should be a gun buyback program
they've worked in many other countries
now many of you will see that list and
you will say but david sir if you're
that polite
not not those things wouldn't have
stopped
this specific shooter in uvalde texas
well some of the things i listed would
have had no impact like the gun show
loophole would have had no impact uh in
this particular case but others would
okay 18 year old shooter uh if you
got got the guns legally right because
these were guns that he was allowed to
get if you limit high capacity weapons
to age 25
then this shooter might have had a
handgun and almost certainly fewer
people die if this particular shooter
had only a handgun
having to have a certificate of gun
insurance
might have dissuaded the guy from going
and getting those guns because it would
have been an additional cost
community support letters everybody has
been posting to social media
that we knew about we knew about this
guy there were adults in the area who
knew this guy was unstable well if
that's true it might have been more
difficult for this shooter to obtain two
or three community support letters from
adults saying i think it's fine for this
individual to have a firearm it would
have been an obstacle a mental health
evaluation could have been an obstacle
okay so some of these things wouldn't
have affected this particular shooting
some of these would the intangible of
course is culture
how do you deal with american gun
culture
uh for many americans that are insular
and don't know what the rest of the
world is like they may not realize how
bizarre it is that we have this
fetishizing of guns celebration of gun
culture condemnation of intelligence and
uh i was it asimov i think it might have
been isaac asimov who said something
along the lines of um and this was in
the 80s i hope i'm quoting this roughly
correctly something along the lines of
uh
my ignorance is seen as a legitimate
counterpoint to your intelligence
it's something like that uh we have a
real cultural problem in the united
states as well and i admit none of my
ideas would impact that okay so there
are some ideas and hey guys
nothing else is working
so we might as well try these things let
me know your thoughts
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below